good evening and welcome to a special
edition of tucker carlson it was a year
ago this month that joe biden promised
to transform this country change it more
than any president had in over a hundred
years he was going to create a new
economy through what he called quote a
once in a generation investment in
america unlike anything we've seen or
done since we built the interstate
highway system
wow that's big what would it cost well
more than four trillion dollars how much
is that exactly well it's more than
twice the gross domestic product of the
entire nation of canada of course most
other countries too
at the washington post they suggested
that joe biden's promise marked quote
the waning of the neo-liberal era
now they described
as centrist liberalism friendly to wall
street when of course it's not exactly
that neoliberalism is looting
with a smokescreen of race and gender
politics so you won't notice that it
happened
but the post told us relax
joe biden's going to give us something
even better better we've ever had think
fdr the new deal but with no downside
so that's what they were telling you a
year ago april 2021 fast forward a year
and it's clear the post got it just
about half right
neoliberalism has indeed waned under joe
biden it will not survive the bid
administration but that's not because
joe biden has rejected neo-liberalism or
found an alternative
something will revolutionize america
like the interstate highway system no
it's because joe biden embraced
neo-liberalism and in so doing reminded
the rest of us tens of millions of
americans that it's horrible
that neoliberalism serves the interests
of virtually no one it's a cover for the
distribution of wealth
a distribution that has become more
lopsided in our age than in any age ever
it is a
shocking
discredit to capitalism it's not
actually
market capitalism it's something
controlled and grotesque
so anyone who thinks about this for
about 30 seconds gets the point
immediately they don't want you to think
about it and that's why biden did what
they always do try to divide the country
along racial lines make you hate your
neighbor so you won't think about where
the money's going he did what barack
obama did but much less artfully
here's joe biden warning us that the
biggest threat to america is not the
fact that you can't afford groceries or
that a tiny number of people is richer
than anyone in human history no the real
threat to you is white supremacy
according to the united states
intelligence community domestic
terrorism from white supremacists
is the most lethal terrorist threat in
the homeland we know now we must
confront and defeat political extremism
white supremacy and domestic terrorism
don't dare call them protesters they
were a riotous mob
insurrectionist
domestic terrorist
white supremacy domestic terrorism
that we must confront and we will defeat
white supremacy
he has no idea what he's even saying
he's just reading a script that's been
around a long time since at least
occupy wall street a little over a
decade ago neoliberal politicians and
media outlets began ranting about race
constantly around that time to get you
to stop thinking about what they were
actually doing and for a long time it
worked
but it can't work forever because it's
not true they've been telling you for a
decade that white supremacy is the real
threat but if you read the news you know
that's probably not true
you've seen a lot of mass killings
recently
and none of them have been motivated by
so-called white supremacy
it's a little bit more complicated than
that
all of a sudden you see people attacked
in race-based crimes
but it's not the storyline that they
have approved it looks exactly
the opposite of what they've been
telling you of course
a black nationalist
mowed down an entire parade full of
christmas celebrators in wisconsin
right another killed a capital police
officer just after joe biden took office
and then recently on the new york city
subway an avowed black nationalist
opened fire
in a crowded car
then a blm activist tried to assassinate
a guy running for mayor in kentucky
again
it doesn't mean that the country has an
epidemic of black supremacy
but it does mean that the constant
harping on race
dividing us by skin color telling some
people that they are hated by the
country itself has consequences
democratic party has embraced a wall
street approved theme
a talking point
about white supremacy and to this day
neoliberals are trying to salvage that
to convince you no it's really true and
that's why merrick garland has never
announced a probe in anything other than
white supremacy it's why general mark
milley isn't reading books about
anything other than white supremacy
so
the talking point may be fake
but they're continuing to throw it at
you
at this point joe biden is not just
inventing racial crimes and attributing
them to millions of people who did
nothing wrong he's also inventing entire
new genders too and this is another
smoke screen
so first it was people should hate each
other based on their skin color now it's
let's leave the entire population
wondering
what a woman is here's joe biden
defending something called trans senior
citizens watch
we're committed to advancing transgender
equality in the classroom on the playing
field at work in our military and our
housing and healthcare systems
everywhere there's always more work to
do
to end the epidemic of violence against
transgender women of color and girls of
color
to ensure transgender seniors can age
with dignity dignity to parents of
transgender children
affirming your child's identity one of
the most powerful things you can do to
keep them safe and healthy
ensuring that trans seniors live with
dignity well who's against that nobody's
against that everybody is for it but
people watching this might wonder well
what about every other kind of senior
what about the rest of the population
that has diminishing hopes of retiring
with dignity
and higher than ever chances of retiring
in poverty
yeah
that's not even addressed and still
they're pushing the story on you so you
don't even have time to think about it
we now have a trans admiral
well the good news is people are
rejecting this because it serves no one
it does not uplift anybody it makes the
population hate each other
so our leaders don't understand that
they don't understand that their ideas
have been rejected by the population
corporate media which carries the ideas
forward into the
living rooms of america doesn't
understand it either but the reality
may wake them up
you're seeing it happen again and again
the rejection of neoliberal ideas
consider the collapse of cnn plus
according to axios quote executives
bucketed cnn plus's potential audience
into three groups with various models of
overlap 29 million cnn super fans they
estimated 24 million subscription video
on demand fans
if people want to pay more for anything
and 36 million global news consumers
so think about those numbers for a
second cnn convinced itself it had 29
million
super fans
that's even less plausible than 81
million votes in a presidential election
and it turned out to be completely
disconnected from reality in the end cnn
plus got about 10 000 viewers
why because people don't really want to
pay to watch that crap to be called
bigots or learn about trans senior
citizens it has nothing to do with their
lives and they know for a fact
it won't improve them
so what are they listening to listen to
people like joe rogan why not because of
his political agenda because he's
interesting and he's curious and he
noticed the world changing all around
him and he wants to know what the hell's
going on and so does everyone else and
that's why rogan gained millions of
subscribers since cnn tried to have him
fired a few months ago
at the same time the company that
employs joe rogan the streaming service
spotify
had to and you may not have seen this
story
offload the obamas to whom they had paid
millions and millions of dollars why
because no one wanted to watch the
obamas either because they had nothing
to say because they're banal they're not
interesting in any way
so take three steps back what are we
watching here
we're watching the end of neoliberalism
and it's core plank the thing it depends
upon to survive which is corporate
control over media
and hence your brain they need to
control what you think or you will
reject them but increasingly they're not
able to because censorship thank god is
dying
and we can credit to some great extent
elon musk for that the richest man in
the world he recently bought twitter
now polls made it very clear that
americans support this why not because
they want another billionaire to own
another media property
but because and the harvard harris poll
found this a majority of americans
understand that twitter was a force for
censorship a force for control over the
population and it turns out most people
since they live in this country and
their citizens would like some say in
how they're governed so they want to
give their opinions out loud without
being punished for it therefore they are
glad that elon musk is promising to end
the censorship of twitter
so why are people rejecting this well
part of the reason is that while joe
biden was making a fool of himself
going on about trans seniors
americans are getting poorer and they
feel it there's no hiding it
many americans can barely afford to live
in their own country watch
year to year meat fish poultry and eggs
jumped almost 14 percent used cars and
trucks up 35 percent
gas up 48 percent blame a tangle of
pressures supply chain issues trucks
waiting up to 30 hours to cross from
mexico into texas
labor shortfalls
oh a food shortage
how many revolutions have been spurred
by food shortages
most of them
and the food that is available is
quickly becoming hard to afford for
people but the body administration
barely acknowledges this
their solution
flood the country with two million new
people
they might all be good people it doesn't
matter the volume is what matters more
people
fewer resources what does that look like
more shortages here's our on bill
malugen
in eagle pass texas it's a scene that
plays out every morning just after
sunrise migrants make their move waiting
across the rio grande entering the u.s
illegally and they continue to come from
all around the world they come in
historic numbers cbp and march alone
reporting more than 221 thousand migrant
encounters that's the highest number in
more than two decades the river can be
deadly fox news this week witnessed the
bodies of multiple drowned migrants
being pulled from the water on the
international bridge in eagle pass as
the end of title 42 on may 23rd looms
groups of migrants are expelled back to
mexico every 30 minutes
right so it's just supply and demand if
you're having a dinner party and you had
just enough food for 12 people but you
invited 1200 people that would mean not
everyone got to eat right
competition for scarce resources like
food and gasoline is a huge huge problem
but there are other effects by the way
while most people coming over the border
are simply looking for a better life
they're good people they want to work
some of them aren't good people and they
don't want to work they want to sell
fentanyl and they are and that means a
lot more overdoses
georgia health officials say fentanyl
has infiltrated street drugs just a few
days ago the gbi and gwinnett county
sheriff's office made a major bust among
the drugs a quarter kilo of fentanyl
they say that equals more than 100
thousand deadly doses six men were
rushed to the hospital thursday
investigators saying they overdosed on a
cocaine cocktail laced with fentanyl the
seattle field office of the d.a has
confiscated 1.1 million fentanyl pills
200 guns from cartel drug traffickers in
the northwest just in the last four
months the problem they say fentanyl is
too affordable and too available it's
just specific here because people can
come here all over and get it dirty and
not get no consequences here so it's
just awful people are dying and not just
in san francisco life expectancy average
life expectancy for american-born
citizens is down so if there's any
measure of failure it's that
and the truth is it doesn't matter what
biden says or any of our political
leaders say you can say whatever you
want but people still live here and they
still have eyes to see and if their
lives are getting worse
they know that you're lying
and the beliefs you are selling are
hollow and the core belief is
neoliberalism
that's been completely discredited and
killed by joe biden
if he's achieved anything as president
it's that
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight